quelle est la quantité de fraises
produite en 2021 dans le monde 9
millions de tonnes métriques ça peut
sembler beaucoup mais c'est loin
derrière le fruit chouchou des humains
la banane dans ton produit 125 millions
de tonnes par an cela dit les fraises
gagnants popularité entre 2008 et 2018
la production mondiale a bondit de 40%.
car les Chinois raffolent de cette
petite baie rouge
la Chine est d'ailleurs le plus grand
producteur mondial avec quelques 3
millions de tonnes métriques les
États-Unis
occupent le deuxième rang le Canada lui
est loin derrière avec 23000 tonnes de
fraises dont la moitié proviennent des
champs du Québec même si elle était déjà
cultivée en Europe dans les jardins de
la Rome antique la fraise telle qu'on la
connaît aujourd'hui à un petit goût des
Amériques car elle a été obtenue grâce
au croisement de deux fraisiers du
Nouveau Monde le fraisier de Virginie
ramené par Jacques Cartier en France à
la fin du XVIème siècle c'est lui qui
donne nos petites phrases des champs si
savoureuses
et un fraisier à grands fruits blancs du
Chili ramenez l'huile par un ingénieur
français qui travaillait au XVIIIe
siècle comme espion au service de Louis
XIV le nom de cet homme était d'ailleurs
prédestiné puisqu'il s'appelait Ahmed
François fraisier
[Musique]